15 000 sounding like 50 000 and
representing so many more from coast to
coast to coast in this great country who
are so happy tabby to see their baseball
team back where they belong you know you
talk about it getting you i felt it
right here in my heart because i i put
myself in the shoes of the players and
what they went through
and and everything they've had to endure
half the roster that's here tonight has
never played here as a blue jay and then
to feel the love coming out of the
stands from the fans the vibe in the
city today was something that i haven't
seen or felt for so long and the players
were so excited about it that ceremony
when they ran on the field through
center field i mean i really felt it and
the players are so excited to do that
i'm right there with you it feels like
opening day plus plus like way more than
even a typical opening day because it
has been
670 days since the blue jays have played
a game at home home opener for the blue
jays tonight it'll be ross stripling
getting the call ross stripling said i
don't take pitching at rogers center
lightly this is very important to him
he is getting ready to make his 17th
start of the second season second career
start at rogers center perez lines one
to left field and the catch is made
by tay oscar hernandez and it's a three
up three down first left-hander daniel
lynch is on the bound for the royals
tonight he's a rookie uh this is his
fifth start select by kansas city 34th
pick overall in 2018.
first baseman number 27
vladimir guerrero jr
you couldn't make it out at home that
was an mvp chant which you know we've
heard a little bit of here and there in
a buffalo but a lot louder a lot clearer
here in toronto with something glad he
might have to get used to the way that
he is
playing right center down for a hit
dyson will keep it in front of him as
vlady smokes one into right for a single
good pitch yeah good start for lynch he
came right at this blue jays offense and
has a scoreless bottom of the first
blue jays coming up with ta oscar
hernandez and he clubs it to left field
and the blue jays have the lead
he was waiting for that fastball
he's going to go join the neighborhood
after that long run
one size fits all you hit it you wear it
and everybody having a good time to
oscar number 16 one nothing blue jays
there's the code he's digging it showing
everybody there all the countries
represented on the back and second two
down about bringing up a guy like george
springer
and wind in the left center of base hit
gretchek will score easily kirk around
the third springer into second with an
rbi double and it is two to nothing
that's a fair ball
dyson over to get it bashed big turn and
now puts the brakes on as the throw will
get into shallow left but if a shed was
heading back to first it's backed up by
dozier
he's probably hearing it from the dugout
right now but he'll have to settle for a
long single there goes beau got a good
jump
and safe
you know i said it wasn't time to run
with tay oscar at the plate but now with
two outs
guriel ahead in the count now was the
time to run
[Applause]
hit the shed on his way home the throw
from ben and tendy not in time
curiel goes up to second on the play and
it's three to nothing
he likes that nice to stay tyson's been
able to get to him
she's the only guy with a hit in the
ball game doubled by dyson in the third
inning and now a two out single to left
center field in the fifth
that ball stroked pretty well to right
center field and it's going to be over
the head of the right fielder grinching
dyson will come around to score lopez
going to third the throw
is not in time it's a triple for nikki
lopez and the royals are on the board
trailing by three to one that's right
drive him in nikki here is salvador
perez uh-oh
go go please salvi get out deep to left
field now defense and it is a gunner
number 26 for salvador perez and the
royals are within one of toronto
burke finds it to center for a base hit
that's a fair ball
valera on his way to third springer
heading to second and in there with a
head first slide with his third hit of
the knot
2-2
round ball to short
the royals will turn two
the blue chase will get a run out of it
no rbi for simeon valera comes in to
score 4-2
so the end result is a run over third
two down and tapia now to face bo buchet
tapia in the 2-1 pitch on a line out to
deep right field dyson on the run he
won't get this one nobody will bow
bushet with a rising line drive over the
right field wall
two-run home run for bulbashan
and the blue jays have opened up a 6-2
lead well it is time for a blue jay
debut and it is left-hander brad hand
just picked up the trade this is his
first day
on the active roster
line base hit left field so with two
strikes nikki lopez goes the other way
and nikki has another two hit game
grounded left side deep short bushet
throws in it's going to get away
so lopez will go to third and home is
going to come around
third base with hand not covering home
plate
oh yeah
might remind you of a
heads-up base running play that the
white sox had when they were in kansas
city recognizing that a base was
uncovered and vance wilson saw it and
sent nikki
all the way
home from first on an error
and a bouncer to guerrero romano's got
to get over and he does not get there in
time
the run will score the call is safe at
first and will the blue jays ask for a
review here
yeah it looks like they want to take a
look at that one here's the feet hits
him in stride
it's it's close
he's out
[Applause]
to end the ball game
[Applause]
because why not i told you he could play
some third pace
acrobatic play to finish it off the boys
are back and they pick up a 6-4 win
over the royals